Hi. Welcome back. I'm here with Joshua Bloch.
Josh is a leading textbook author, Effective Java, a book on concurrency in Java,
a devilish book on Java puzzlers,
and was one of the leaders who brought Java to us
and worked on the early APIs, including the collections class and so on.
What was that process like?
[Josh Bloch, Google Engineer:] I as in the right place at the right time,
and I have always enjoyed APIs have kind of been the recurrent theme of the past 20 years,
but I used to write them for 10 or 15 people.
All of a sudden I was writing them for millions of people.
It was chaotic. That's the way the internet was back in those days.
Type systems should exist to serve the programmer and not vice versa.
If you find yourself constantly fighting with the type system,
writing a program that won't compile, and just spend lots of time jamming the thing
through the compiler, and it wears you out.
You don't really gain any insight in the process--
then there's something wrong with the type system, and I believe
that Java's wildcards have that problem.
In the case of Java, you've got an existing language that was designed around
storing static typing, and if you try to put dynamic stuff into it,
there's a little bit of an impedance mismatch.
Things that are added to languages after the fact tend not to reside comfortably in the language.
When languages grow too much and stray too far from their roots,
you generally end up with big messes.
Now, we talked about reliability of algorithms.
You did a blog post about a bug in a decades old algorithm on binary search.
What happened there?
That was a an amazing story.
I was at Carnegie Mellon University for 1982 to 1990 or so,
and when I'd first arrived I took a PhD-level algorithms course from John Bentley,
who was a brilliant and funny, and he started out by asking us all,
"How many of you know how to write binary search?" We all raised our hands
We were hot shot computer scientists.
We got our bachelor's and we felt we knew what we were doing.
He said, "Okay. Fine. Take out a piece of paper and write it. You've got 10 minutes, and then we'll talk."
Ten minutes later, he said, "Okay. Who got it right?" Everybody raised their hand.
He picks one person and says, "Put your algorithm on the board."
The person does, and he tears it apart.
Of course, the person had not gotten it right. It was broken.
The point of his lecture was that you need to use invariants in your code.
In particular, in binary search the invariants are tricky,
and if you don’t think in terms of invariants, you'll get it wrong.
Language design is always going to be an aesthetic exercise.
You need good taste if you're going to do it, and you're operating partially from the gut.
Empiricism is one important part of what you're doing,
but if something feels wrong or feels ugly then it's probably a bad idea.
There are some people who are really good at doing the aesthetic stuff
and at sort of placing themselves in the shoes of the programmer
and saying, yes, this'll feel right.
Other people can't do that, but they're really good at looking at a grammar and saying,
"I'm afraid that you're going to end up with an ambiguity here,
if not now when we add these other features that we intend to add."
The point is empiricism is great. I would even say it's necessary now, but it's not sufficient.